the arrests of former interior Minister
Marios Kaminsky and his one-time Deputy
Mach wasik have turned a simmering
political rivalry into a constitutional
crisis Kaminsky and vasik had taken
refuge for several hours in the Palace
of their political Ally president Andre
Duda it was an extraordinary Act of
defiance directed at Poland's recently
elected prime minister Donald Tusk who
responded by accusing the president of
obstructing
justice
to be direct it is obvious sabotage I'm
very very concerned about this and it's
not about wasik or Mr Kaminski that's
the Court's decision but I'm worried
that president dudo is involved the
specific dispute is over whether
president dudo was legally entitled to
Grant pardons to Kaminsky and vasik
after they were convicted of abuse of
power in 2015 the Supreme Court said he
wasn't entitled he disagrees and accuses
Tusk of brutality Mr
I must tell you that as president of the
Republic of Poland and as a man who
believes in a just and honest Poland I
am deeply shaken by this situation by
the fact that they were put in prison
despite a presidential pardon and with
such Zeal and such
brutality at its core this is a bitter
power struggle involving the new
center-left government led by Tusk and
the presidency led by Duda who remains
closely aligned with the previous
government of the right-wing nationalist
Law And Justice party
Duda is making it clear he will oppose
tusk's agenda and duda's presidential
term runs until mid
2025 it's going to be a very tough 18
months Paul Brennan Al
[Applause]
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer